قال القاضي مور أيضًا إنه
لا يعتقد أنه
يجب السماح لعضو مسلم في
الكونجرس بالتواجد في الكونجرس.
أنا مسؤول منتخب
ثلاث فترات كان عليّ أن أقسم على الكتاب المقدس أن
عليك أن تقسم على الكتاب المقدس لتكون
مسؤولاً منتخبًا في الولايات
المتحدة الأمريكية ، وهو يدعي أن
المسلم لا يمكنه أداء القسم الأخلاقي
على الكتاب المقدس الذي لا تفعله "  في الواقع ، يجب أن
أقسم على كتاب مقدس مسيحي ، يمكنك أن تقسم
على أي شيء لا أعرفه حقًا إذا كنت
تعلم أنه يمكنك القسم على
الكتاب المقدس اليهودي ثلاث مرات ، أنا متأكد من
أنك اخترت الكتاب المقدس ولكن القانون  ليس
أنه عليك أن تقسم على
كتاب مقدس مسيحي ليس هو القانون ، فأنت
لا تعلم أن تيد كروكيت
حسنًا ، لا أعرف أن دونالد
ترامب فعل ذلك عندما جعلناه
رئيسًا لأنه  كريستيان وقد
اختارها وهذا ما أراده
الذي أردناه أن أقسم على تي
كروكيت مع المزيد من الحملة ،
حظًا سعيدًا الليلة ، شكرًا جزيلاً
لوجودك هنا ، ستتفاعل اللجنة الخاصة بي ، شكرًا لك سيدي